We have to talk about something really important
today.
And the reason that this is so important is
that we can't solve problems unless we understand
them.
And over the last few days, has different
folks have weighed in on the violent Trump
insurrection that took place last week?
I've seen more and more commentaries that
are missing the boat when it comes to the
immediate and proximate causes of the insurrection
and of the coup attempt.
And specifically, I'm talking about claims
that ultimately what happened last week comes
down to merely economic unfairness and inequality
and anger by the so-called working class.
And even lots of people that I greatly respect
have weighed in on this issue, and I believe
they are wrong.
I'll give you an example with total peace
and love, my former economics professor from
the University of Massachusetts, economist
Richard Wolffe, tweeted, quote, What was seen
in the Capitol building of Washington on January
six was another manifestation of angry working
class people.
This will only continue unless basic changes
happen in this country.
We need to do something about the inequality
of this society.
I love Richard Wolffe.
He's been a guest on this show a dozen times.
I was recently on his show.
This is the worst take I've ever seen from
Richard Wolffe, who typically has really great
takes to some degree.
This idea is a version of class reductionism.
Class reductionism is the idea that in the
end, all oppression, strife, violence, unrest,
it all comes down merely to class struggle
and racial struggle is really class struggle
and nationalistic struggle is really class
struggle, etc.
It's a gender struggle is really class struggle,
and that if we reduce inequality, it's going
to solve all of these different problems.
And I think we have to be very careful because
nobody's claiming that economics and class
struggle are not important in in just about
everything that we see in our political system.
And even those claiming that it played a role
last week are right, but in this particular
case, the class struggle aspect of this, absent
a more detailed and comprehensive analysis,
falls woefully short in explaining what happened
last week.
Remember shortly after Donald Trump was elected,
there was a whole bunch of talk about this
was about economic anxiety, economic anxiety,
motivated people to give Donald Trump a shot
because he spoke to those economic anxieties.
And to some degree, it's true in that Donald
Trump as a faux populist, right wing populist,
that rhetoric certainly appeals to economic
anxiety in many people.
But then as we had more information about
the motivations of Trump voters, we came to
learn that while there was economic anxiety
on both the left and the right, that the right
was motivated to vote for Donald Trump by
many other things, including the resonance
of Donald Trump's xenophobia, fear of losing
perceived or actual status to immigrants,
coming in and taking jobs to brown people,
asshole countries.
That entire narrative.
And case in point, there are so many counter
points to the class reductionist argument
or explanation about last week riots that
the explanation of this is merely class struggle
would be dangerous to accept as a full explanation
for what we saw, including, by the way, that
many of the people that participated in the
insurrection, they had the money to not only
travel to Washington, D.C., but to stay in
hotels that aren't cheap.
Now, I know that there were groups funding
the travel, but for many people that wasn't
the case.
These people were able to afford going to
D.C., taking time off from work if they have
a job, if they need to work and staying in
expensive hotels.
And so there are.
So that's one aspect.
The other aspect is there are tons of people
on the left and right that economically are
way worse off than the protesters rioters
last week.
But they were not there.
And there are even examples of wealthy people
going to D.C. on private jets to participate
in the riot, although that's anecdotal.
Obviously, most of these rioters did not fly
in on private jets.
But the point here is that there is something
unique to those who, yes, mostly are not particularly
privileged economically, but there is a significant
xenophobic component.
There is a significant ignorance to reality
component people who fall for, listen, if
this was just economic anxiety, you wouldn't
see that the people at the riot are the people
who fell for the obvious lies from Trump about
a stolen election.
What was really the most common factor among
the rioters was that they fell for and they
believed that the election was stolen from
Donald Trump, which is demonstrably untrue.
There were rich and poor people who fell for
that.
There were elites and non elites who fell
for that, and importantly, poor people who
didn't fall for it.
Weren't there rioting people who were significantly
more economically disadvantaged or oppressed
by the economic system? Weren't there rioting
because they didn't believe this stupid narrative
that the election was stolen?
And so I very much appreciate the class aspect
that at a general level has generated anxiety
and a desire for change.
The people that participated in this riot
exposed the Trump movement for what it really
is.
And it's not merely an economic anxiety movement.
It's a particularly extreme, radical, conspiratorial
worldview informed by being uninformed.
That shirt, to some degree overlaps with aspects
of economic anxiety.
But the truth is that at this point, economic
anxiety is a reality for a huge portion of
this country.
That there I agree with Richard Wolffe and
others when half the country can't meet.
An unexpected four hundred dollar expense
without going into debt, just about any group,
unless you're saying we're only serving private
jet owners, just about any group, health care
workers, factory workers, educational workers,
whoever, all of these groups will include
a lot of economic anxiety, but that doesn't
mean that that's the cause of violent, radical
insurrectionist violence.
And let's not miss the forest for the trees
and pretend that it goes away simply by solving
economic inequality.
You listen, you'll solve economic inequality.
And a lot of these people will be furious
that now they are on the same level as a lot
of people that they don't deserve.
They don't believe, deserve believe to be
economically stable.
And that gets us back to the xenophobia and
the rest of it.
So I think that these analyzes missed the
mark.
I've seen a bunch of them, and I'm curious
to hear your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter
at
David Pakman,